hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play well I mean I
actually don't know the title of this
game because someone named Jack the
Slendy killer US 173 sent this to me and
there must have been something wrong
with the download link because game got
kind of I don't know corrupted or
something like that hold shift to run I
need to talk to the king of here
oh man but I mean what I saw so far it
looked like a really cool adventurous
little game that I want to give a good
playthrough here for greetings
adventurer we earn in need of your help
okey dokey the nasty old Jack and his
henchmen keep sneaking into our Castle
at night to steal our gold sorry the
text right over my face please defeat
Jack in his henchmen to get our gold
back
he had eased to town into the woods and
you're sure to find a man your reward
will be great
okay mr. king you see you're seem
protected in your castle there even
though you're on the outside I look at
that guy up there yeah sorry about the
little bugs it seems like this game
might be a little unstable I don't know
when I was up download again I kept
getting random flashes and black screens
and and I don't really know what what's
going on but hopefully that'll sort it
out I mean if it doesn't work you know
me mark why are always breaking the game
over and over again so hopefully we can
work out all the issues and OH
left-click to attack all the paths and
find Jack you got it buddy anyway I
really liked the art direction of this
game it's made on the Uni engine and you
can see it's got the cell shaded
graphics that are kind of cool to give a
comic book art style cartoony feel to a
game that's always in in demand because
you know I like to have creative
projects really reach out and try to try
something different in the game and
that's always up important in terms of
indie games especially because you got
to find a unique niche for your game and
oh we got me but not too long I'm fine
there
good old call of duty mechanics rub the
blood off your face and you're good to
go ok these guys can't stand hello have
you seen a mr. Jack mr. Jack O'Lantern
about yay foot high orange lots of oh
man did you guys see that I got some
sort of a flash there I don't know
that's what was happening before when I
was installing game
I don't know why that's happening hope
that hopefully that won't happen too
much longer sorry for the interruption
we'll just continue continuing via u
review here and hopefully some stability
issues will not be present as we move
forward so we're going into the
mountainous area to fly to find jacket
uh-oh Oh looks like we got a bunch of
them here but we can take them right
guys cuz we're so strong and handsome
yeah how this key Shou got me good
it's my época game techniques here Wow
go fly in the air that's ok huh
got him good and they'll match for me I
like the way the bodies despawn
instantly that uh help save game
resources to get models in and out
quickly through the game so that these
indie games can feel like they are
worked well hahahahaha this will be fun
that was Jax are you kids here hi let's
go let's go Jack what you got a what new
oh no two in one let's go Jack let's go
buddy let's go haha guys guys are you
still there hello is anybody still there
is there anybody watching uh wait what
wait no ok wait sorry guys uh if you're
still out there um something seems to
have happened to have another one of the
bugs that was happening before I don't
know why but it's kind of getting well
there's another flashing it was that as
I another enemy I need to slay what the
hell looks like a little little kid
hello hi there haha oh well alright then
kind of weird but alright just kind of
stand in there okay the objective is to
head back to town let's just go back to
town and finish this quest and finish up
this review here so hopefully we'll be
able to do just fine okay um anyway
now five four nine one one what is your
emergency okay so um it seems like the
game has become fully unstable here
sorry I don't know my objective is still
the same but some of the the trees seem
to be popping in and out um probably
them from with the optimization of the
game terms of loading the grass textures
seem to have this beard okay it's fine
oh this is a happy fun adventure Phil I
can't move forward or can it before
there was there something there I can't
move forward
something keeps blocking my way so
problem with the air hit boxing for
interacting with objects on the ground
oh okay okay in case you couldn't tell
some people so though sarcasm this is a
horror game by the by if you can what I
owe
hi buddy oh no I mean some my sword is
now upside down oh this game is so
glitchy
what the hell what the hell that's the
night that was on the castle wall there
so some textures seemed to be missing on
the oh boy
welp seems like oh no mark broke the
game again the worst way possible oh hi
hi hi there you want to go away from me
uh talk to the king okay what the hell
what the hell okay all right go hi you
stupid bastard hello mr. Kane great work
adventurer you defeated Jack error 53
unknown there's that error again Oh
this your king you wanna please defeat
Jack in his henchmen and get our goal
back at east of the town into the woods
and you're sure to find them there your
reward will be great
my reward death death death
hashtag death or the hell okay going
back at the town good thing I still got
by sward here somehow okay I don't have
a sword it I do have a sward it's true
bow oh lordy can I stab you in face
don't you cut I can't go left what I
everything wait no no I live
the controls are backwards hello gotta
stab you scissor that sidarsky